hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today i will
be taking a deep dive into all the
latest events in the boku no hero story
including ochako single-handedly
rescuing deku's hero career and possibly
his life deku finally surpassing all
might in one very important aspect and i
will be talking about how these new
developments changed everything we
thought we knew about the mha manga this
was a more important chapter than many
people realize so let's get into it if
you enjoyed the boku no hero content on
this channel and you want us to keep it
going you know what to do just leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps a lot with the
youtube algorithm and of course if
you're new to animeopro or maybe watch
our videos but you haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications a big thank you to
all of our anime opera patrons who make
videos like this one possible i will
talk more about patreon at the end of
the video but for now please be advised
that this video will of course contain
boku no hero manga spoilers please
proceed with caution you have been
warned we started off with a quick
flashback to ochako's childhood in the
previous chapter ochako jumped onto
center stage quite literally and she
addressed the angry anti-deku protesters
directly in an attempt to get them to
accept deku in the flashback we see that
while most people loved seeing heroes
fight crime and most people were amazed
by the powers that the heroes
demonstrated adorable little ochako was
more amazed by something else rather
than the heroes themselves ochako loved
seeing how the actions of the heroes
made other people feel she loved seeing
how happy people became when they saw a
hero in action she loved the fact that
heroes were able to make other people
feel good just by showing up and doing
their job as we know ochako's parents
always worked really hard but they
struggled financially and as a result
they always had an exhausted expression
on their face but a hero showing up to
save the day was something that could
instantly change the look on their faces
and on the faces of many other people no
matter what problems and worries all of
these people might have had heroes had
the incredible power to brighten their
mood and give them a spark of hope even
in the worst of times ochako initially
decided to become a hero in order to
help her parents financially and make
their lives easier and this has led to
many memes about ochako just wanting
money and about staying coming after her
if he ever finds out what her
motivations for being a hero are however
ochoko didn't really become a hero for
money it's not that simple for ochoko
the money is just a means to an end and
the actual end goal is to make her
parents happy from this brief flashback
we can see that for ochako heroism is
not actually about money it is about the
power to make other people happy yes she
wants to help her parents financially
because she believes that this will make
them happier but she also wants to make
other people happy by being a hero she
wants to brighten people's day and give
them hope in difficult times and for
ochoko that is exactly what heroism is
about what she wants to do now is
convince this angry crowd that deku is a
true hero someone who has sacrificed
everything to give hope to the people of
japan yes the current situation is
disturbing and chaotic but deku and
other heroes like him represent the
final spark of hope they are the light
at the end of the tunnel for all of
those scared and desperate people in
japan heroes like deku shouldn't be
rejected by the people they should be
embraced as their last and best hope for
turning things around as ochako speaks
to the crowd using a megaphone the
people in the crowd finally start
noticing just how beat up and exhausted
deku looks that furry girl who was saved
by deku in chapter 310 is stunned to see
that after he saved her deku just kept
on fighting without taking a break for
such a long time another person in the
crowd is like wait you want the rest of
us to end up looking like this guy but
ochako tells him that no the ones who
will shoulder all of the burden are the
heroes the heroes will do everything to
protect the people they will give their
blood and sweat for the people and the
only thing that the heroes ask is for
the people to give them some time to
give deku some time deku is deeply moved
by ochako's words and actions with tears
in his eyes deku calls out uraraka-san
and in that emotional moment i can't
help but think dude just call her by her
first name what are you doing dekku what
are you doing anyway ochoko then comes
right out and tells the crowd the truth
she doesn't downplay the situation or
sugarcoat anything she says plainly that
as of right now the heroes cannot
guarantee the people safety and in fact
the heroes are just as frightened as
everyone else's everyone is in the same
boat now heroes and civilians alike and
because they're all in the same boat
they must work together to get out of
this dire situation that is the only way
that they can succeed in their fight to
one day restore order because of that
ochako calls on the people to cooperate
with the heroes so that tomorrow they
can all smile together in that moment
ochako is distracted for just a second
by the thought of toga's crazy smile
this was probably just ochako
remembering her previous conversation
with toga although i'd like to think
that this is foreshadowing that we will
be seeing toga again soon she just kind
of disappeared during that final
showdown in jakku and i know i might be
looking too much into this but i
definitely want to see toga do something
epic i mean she hasn't even had the
chance to avenge twice yet so i'm sure
that she's out there plotting something
big ochako then pleads with the crowd to
give deku some time to rest and recover
at the end of the day deku is just a
normal high school kid and yet he has
shown an incredible amount of resolve
and dedication when it comes to
protecting others he is still a high
school kid he has a lot to learn but he
has already sacrificed so much and he is
willing to sacrifice even more if only
the people would believe in him if only
they would let him stay here at ua at
least for now we are then reminded of
the very first chapter of mha the moment
when deku says that this is the story of
how he became the greatest hero we then
see deku dropping to his knees with
tears streaming down his face the people
gathered there are kind of stunned by
this and it is clear that they are
beginning to feel some compassion for
deku that is when two people who were
saved by deku in the past the furry girl
and kota pushed their way through the
crowd and towards deku as kota and the
furry girl run up to deku to help him
and embrace him we see the following
words this is the story of how we all
became the greatest heroes and that is
how this epic chapter ends
wow i actually loved that ending
especially those words on the final page
now this is of course a battle shown in
series and this chapter had literally no
action in terms of fighting or anything
like that and yet this was such an
amazing and important chapter ochako
overcoming her shyness and standing up
for deku in front of everyone deku
absolutely overcome with emotion and
then the people that deku saved in the
past coming to his aid and setting an
example for the others deku's sacrifices
and good deeds from the past are now
bearing fruit the people who know him
and who got his help in the past have
his back and as a result the angry crowd
is beginning to see the truth about who
this young hero really is and of course
those words on the final page this is
the story of how we all became the
greatest heroes this is actually a
massive development in the story in a
very important way deku just surpassed
all might back in the first chapter when
we first saw the words this is the story
of how i became the greatest hero deku
was still completely obsessed with all
might and he wanted to be exactly like
all might but now deku has finally
realized that allmight had his faults
and the biggest one was his insistence
on working alone and doing everything by
himself i spoke about this at length in
my previous mha video and if you didn't
watch that then definitely check it out
but essentially all might had the best
of intentions and he wanted to do
everything himself in order to protect
others but by doing this all might
inadvertently sabotage deku from the
start by setting an unrealistic standard
for what a true hero should be all might
liked doing as much as possible on his
own and he wanted to save everyone and
solve every problem by himself and this
made him the symbol of peace for an
entire nation but no one man can do all
of those things at least not forever
ultimately all might tried to do too
much he sustained a life-altering injury
and eventually this forced him to retire
after he retired the people of japan
lost their symbol of peace and the hero
society eventually crumbled because it
relied too much on one man once almight
was no longer capable of protecting the
hero society regular people quickly lost
hope the villains were emboldened and
the society crumbled this latest arc
showed us very clearly that deku was
going down the same path as all might he
wanted to become the new symbol of peace
by doing everything on his own and
protecting everyone without any regard
for his own well-being while this is a
brave and noble thing in theory it also
nearly got him killed and again i've
said this many times before if deku ends
up getting himself killed then he
literally can't help anyone so clearly
doing what he was doing is not a good
strategy no matter how brave and bold it
might seem after being confronted by his
classmates from 1a deku finally began to
realize that he can't be almight and he
can't do everything on his own and
frankly he shouldn't try to be like all
might deku has to learn to rely on his
friends and on other heroes and hero
students trying to become the next
almight wouldn't be good for anyone it
wouldn't be good for deku because he
would destroy his own body very quickly
and it wouldn't be good for the rest of
society either because even if deku
became as great as all might at his peak
eventually deku would get older or he
would get injured and he too would have
to step down and then what society would
again eventually crumble because they
put all their faith in one hero and now
that hero is gone and just as deku's
world view has finally evolved the
entire narrative of the story has now
evolved with him this is no longer the
story that it was at the beginning this
is no longer the story of how deku
became the greatest hero instead this is
now the story of how deku and his
friends all became the greatest heroes
together that is actually huge it is a
narrative game changer and i for one am
very happy to see this happening so many
times in the past we've seen deku
carelessly neglecting his own well-being
in order to help someone else even
before he had a quirk deku was that type
of person we saw it in the very first
chapter and this was a huge part of his
character but now
324 chapters in deku is finally
beginning to understand that you can be
heroic even when you work together with
others you can be a hero without taking
ridiculous risks all the time because
you're trying to do everything by
yourself i expect that from now on this
story will focus less on deku and his
powers individually and more on decline
the other heroes and hero students
working together as a carefully
assembled team like i said i'm really
happy that the story is developing in
this direction and i just loved the
emotion and the power of this seemingly
actionless chapter but let me know what
you guys think did you like this chapter
as much as i did even though it didn't
have any fighting and do you agree with
me that this could change the entire
narrative of the story but even more
importantly are ochako and deku finally
going to get a room
don't worry i know that this was not
necessarily a romantic moment just a
great friendship moment but you just
know that the shippers are going to run
with this so i might as well make the
joke at any rate don't forget to leave
your feedback down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this boku no hero video
and you want to see more in the future
just leave that like it only takes a
second but it helps a lot and if you're
new to anime opera or maybe you watch
our videos but you haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications you really have to
go through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting that
option that says all if you don't do
that you're still gonna miss a ton of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar i want to give a quick
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons who make videos like this one
possible special thank you to alpha
sigma he is an absolute mad lad and
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrata pate heffa
algital hinokamien water the toasted chi
the spike dylan isidore spidey life
tinel tungsten tarkis big buddhist and
monkey d quilly finally thank you to all
of our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh the red
haired raven on hell cruise ratheora
very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
joanne garcia ted no ted fat boy games
corey mcgowan and soul ray slice and
dice if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value to you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these legendary people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you